الى بريطانيا وملف اللاجئين ترتفع ارقام
الهجره عبر بحر المونش سناء بعد اخرى
لتتضعف بعد ذلك رغم الاجراءات
المتشدده للحد منها ورغم الخطط المتعاقبه
للحكومه البريطانيه المحافظه لمكافحه هذه
الظاهره الحساسه سياسيا خصوصا مع فرنسا
حكومه سوناتا تصر على المضيق قدما بخطط
ترحيل المهاجرين الى رواندا الاحصائيات
الرسميه ابهرت زياده اعداد المهاجرين
الذين يقطعون بحر المانش بقوارب صغيره
بشكل غير قانوني الى الاراضي البريطانيه
بمقدار 150 ضعفا وذلك خلال السنوات
الاربعه الماضيه قام اكثر من خمسه واربعين
الف و700 شخص برحلات محفوفه بالمخاطر عبر
القناه عام 2022 يعني زياده بنسبه 60% عن
عام 2021 الذي شهد عبور حوالي 28
فن وخمسمائه مهاجر غير شرعي علما بان
الرقم لم يتعدى 1800 شخص عام 2000 2019
العام الماضي سجل ايضا اكبر عدد من
الاشخاص الذين عبروا قناه المانش في يوم
واحد ووصل عددهم الى
1295 شخص متجاوزا الرقم القياسي السابق
الذي قرب 1200 شخص في نوفمبر 2000 و 2021
[موسيقى]